notice that the uh weapon has this curve
you
see that's that's an energy line so as I
come around I don't want to lose contact
I'm going to keep contact come around
and I will be able when I hit the the
convex Apex of that curve that's where
I'm going to put my Apex of my curve and
that'll do the displacing for me
okay so
around and I can be pretty straight but
his boken is being
displaced if you do it all early you see
it's in the way and I got to move it and
I got to take this angle over here so I
would like for you to feel just the the
energy of his of the curvature you
you'll feel the yin and that's where you
feel the you change to Y so you'll feel
it
it'll displace on its own without you
having to do anything drastic with your
hands okay try it
again all right so he he's going to he's
going to go around that and I'm going to
feel when who right when I feel that
displacement
thing you're going to feel the the the
energy of the two weapons are going to
change and I'm going to keep it and now
I have to hang
right when I feel it boom and you see I
have
the right through
[Music]
okay let's go so one thing you got to
pay attention to is as he's coming in
that shouldn't happen we're now
mismatched okay that there's no there's
no energy for me to get back on the Yang
side of this so he's going to do Yang
here he's going to just Place me it's
going to take a lot of muscle for me to
do that so as a metric you can use the
fact that he's coming around go sorry
he's coming around that our swords stay
even you see for most of it until I
decide to let him go by and that's when
I'm coming in okay don't let him
close the gap too
early so I'm coming around this time so
I'm coming around boom there he goes
he's coming back in I'm going to clear
and
this okay notice that I'm still stuck on
him and what I'm doing is rotating the
cross around this way
here we don't lose cont
go
around
around very very small little
[Music]
flick
when do I flick right when I feel his
energy right when I feel
[Music]
there just follow the in
space follow the in
face okay so just like if I doing you
keep your B in your hand just like uh
just usually throw it don't throw it
okay so I'm going to do an an i adhesion
right so I'm going to get that pressure
there and then I'm going to be able to
move it got it
so all that kind of stuff that I'm doing
I have to first before I I can do that I
have to be sensitive to what is his
energy level so that I can get this
going do you see and then as he relaxes
and tries to counter it becomes even
harder it becomes even harder to feel
that so I have to increase my
sensitivity you understand okay so
before you can do ien you have to feel
the yinong shift so that this is a drill
in the yiny Yang shifting okay and uh in
other words as I come around
I don't have to really do anything with
my book and it just sort of Falls in
place he he'll go you see and he comes
back in and I don't have to do
anything it's just fitting in those gin
spaces so same thing here I come around
I I don't have to do anything with my
book and it can just fall go
go just falling
you see that are you're going like
this so if you pay attention to my moves
all my moves are forward so as I'm
coming around and he
defends I'm just charging you see I'm
just charging
someone oh that means I can't contest
with his weapon okay so one more move
for this so he's going to come around
I'm going to do again I'm just fitting
You See It just
fits don't do stuff with your
sword it'll
fit
H let me get my
hand in
H
I'm going to give his a little
pull over my
head
you can go
leg
sorry
legs
[Music]
or listen to the pull on his
weapon
listen okay let's try